what's interesting is how much impact a
great movie villain will have with so
little screen time
when you think about villains what are
the characters who come to mind well i
would say the greatest villain in movie
history is darth vader
that that would be a great villain that
comes to mind
uh hans gruber
in die hard i think is is also an
incredible villain
i mean
here's what's interesting the villains
tend to always be
more interesting
than the the protagonist than the hero
why
i i i think the reason that villains
are
much more interesting and much more
popular
than the heroes is
and i'm sorry to say this i think
they're relatable
because they speak to a darker
version
of ourselves that exists in all of us
that we resist
and the villain is caught up in a
you know in at least not necessarily the
villain but but as an audience member
we're caught up in the like oh well you
know i'd never do that but i guess
darth vader would
do this thing that i would never do
right and it's it's always a
a battle internally over morality
and i think what makes villains
interesting especially really
well-crafted villains
is that they don't think what they're
doing is wrong
from their perspective from the
villain's point of view
they're
right i mean there's a reason that
you know there is the term thanos was
right right like
thanos's mission
was to set the galaxy right
and
wipe out half of all life in the galaxy
so that other life could thrive
there's a lot of logic that doesn't
quite work in the marvel avengers series
you know that that thanos ended up being
the the main villain of but
people kind of look at that and say well
he has a point you know he has a point
about you know wasting resources
of you know
so
that's where that term thanos was right
came from
and he is
you know at least in the movie infinity
war
he's such a big part of that film it
really is his journey through parts of
the marvel universe
right experiencing all of these heroes
that you know we've come to see through
their own individual movies and in uh
infinity war
you're you're on thanos journey he's the
lead character of infinity war
he's the one that is influencing all of
the events
and what's interesting is when you look
at the screen time for villains this is
what this is what's amazing is you can
see a movie that has a great movie
villain like a star wars whether it's
you know the original series
or anakin skywalker and in the prequels
and what's interesting is how much
impact a great movie villain will have
with so little screen time
very little screen time
but the villain influences all of the
other characters in the movie because
the protagonist is constantly having to
react to
some
something
that the main villain is responsible for
always they're the one that's like even
though they may not be present on screen
the villain
the main villain in a story is always
the person that is influencing events
so
and darth vader to me is the combination
of probably some of the best aspects of
of
villains from all types uh you know
whether it be from you know movie
serials or comic books it's
fairly easy to argue that darth vader
was very influenced by dr doom from the
fantastic four comic books created by
stan lee
the look of darth vader kind of based on
that also based on
a little bit of a samurai in there um in
terms of the helmet and other aspects of
darth vader's character and the fact
that it took
you know
uh you know david prowses an actor uh
and then james earl jones as a voice
actor to kind of create this and also
the physical look you know the costume
designers and and whatnot and and ralph
bakshi to kind of design the character
or versions of the character to what it
became on screen so so much went into
the creation of darth vader as a villain
and that darth vader has a tragic
backstory that only a piece of it
becomes revealed in the second movie in
which darth vader appeared the empire
strikes back
you know villains have layers
heroes are pretty much like i want to do
the good thing i'm going to resist doing
the bad thing
okay
uh villains
there's much more
tragedy pain
trauma and i think that that actually
makes them
more relatable
not in the sense that we would want to
act out uh and or emulate any of the
things that a a villain on screen would
do
in particular say villains from
quentin tarantino movies right they were
the
know main antagonists of those of those
of quentin tarantino's films
but like it's a way to kind of like
exercise your own demons
right like
and that's why i think that movie
villains are so popular and that's why i
think that
i don't even think i need to look at a
poll i'm i'm certain that if you looked
up best movie villains darth vader is
going to be in the number one if not in
the top three position
and and i think that they'll always be a
source of fascination i think i think
that
of late though
it's gotten to the point now where
there's a deconstruction of villains
okay it's like well what led to this
person becoming the villain right with
movies like cruella or even the star
wars prequels right like what led to
this person they started out as good but
then they became bad well what is that
journey like and that's become a whole
other
genre unto itself right the
deconstruction of a movie villain and
showing it from their point of view
and i guess from darth vader's point of
view you know he wanted to set the
galaxy right and you know uh
so from darth vader's point of view from
anakin skywalker's point of view he was
doing the right thing
i don't know i i think that you know
from thanos's point of view the same
thing from other great movie villains
point of views
you know
they had a mission they were trying to
fulfill i just think that um
villains always tend to be the most
interesting characters
are villains always the most unlikable
or is unlikability and villain two
separate characters
yeah i i i don't know i unlikeability
is i i don't know it's like an um
unlikable in in the sense of you know i
mean you're gonna like the villain
otherwise the hero has no journey right
uh and and
yeah i think unlikable is you know maybe
a term better used for like a side
character or whatnot or an unlikable
character um
might be better way to describe han solo
in the first star wars movie where he
was kind of uh he was selfish he was out
for himself he only cared about money
didn't care about the cause that the
that uh princess leia was on
and he was you know parts of him were
unlikable he was still it's like it's
harrison ford he's very attractive
man that chiseled jaw sure i'm very
envious of that church
exactly he beats me so but he's you know
um
he's unlikable and has a redemption
right so that redemption arc is
important not just you know and we've
seen it happen more with villains
i don't think necessarily thanos had a
redemption arc um you know but the story
of darth vader is a redemption arc which
is a very christian story
what about female villains
yeah uh
because
i'm sorry to interrupt but walter
white's wife in breaking bad was she
really a villain or she just unlikeable
oh that's interesting
uh
yeah i mean
i would i would probably say
unlikable but
from her
point of view i feel like the audience
can relate to
the you know the moral dilemma that
she's faced with which influences her
decision-making so i i don't know that i
would consider her necessarily a villain
but but
you know unlikable in the sense that
walter white is you know
he's our guy he's the it's right you
understand stories about him
and
but i but i feel some empathy for her
from the standpoint of well
she's making the decisions for what she
thinks is best
so while while i would understand with
some understand and empathize with her
decision making wouldn't necessarily
agree with it
was there a villain in amelie i mean
look i think
i i think i think the villain in amelie
was amelie's agoraphobia really and her
um ability to relate to other people
that was the thing that she needed to
overcome
here she is kind of in love with the
world but the shy quiet girl who you
know um
[Music]
has
uh you know
she she gains
this
you know delight over connecting people
with
with some aspect of them that that
reawakens some love right which begins
with that little box of toys and the
the
uh
and and her journey
the sort of you know like she's she's
doing good in that sense but then you
know the person she's thinking about all
these other people and how she can kind
of help them along the way and she's she
thinks about herself last right uh but
but then that journey becomes about her
you know overcoming her own agoraphobia
i don't know if that could be considered
a villain in the movie but it's
certainly the challenge that the
protagonist must overcome and i would
say a mild case of agoraphobia uh in her
case
sure
it's not like panic no no no but yeah
but you know she
she repelled from
connecting
with a
with someone who could be a lover for
her she repelled from it and she
walked away fearful from it she resisted
it
and and then
it comes full force
that's such a great movie amelia is such
a such a movie that is in a category all
its own that defies
you know
you know
it's such a simple story and yet a
complex one all at once
and it's not a story that is told well
very often
so having seen it in the theater when it
first came out
in that movie is is just
incredible
who are some of the smartest villains
you can think of
well
i don't know that i would classify them
as smart
i i actually
like when there's a decent bond villain
but the fact that they keep getting
tripped up by bond
means they're not very good villains
you know it's i mean it's almost it's
almost
laughable or comical
that so many movie villains
i feel like these movie villains should
watch movies with other villains because
then they'd see kind of like the roots
of their mistakes
which is one
the main cause of death of a movie
villain is falling from a high place
so don't be anywhere high like if you're
gonna construct a throne room in a
half-constructed death star try not to
put it somewhere where there's a chasm
where you could fall to your death
i'm referencing of course
uh the return of the jedi and
and the emperor and his untimely demise
or did he die i don't know it was never
really explained
uh in any case
so
yeah i i
i don't know i think the smartest
villains are always kind of
several steps ahead of
their protagonist
and
i mean to me the uh
the trio of villains in the original
raiders of the lost ark
i think are i think were great because
at the end
you know indiana jones did not win
he simply kept his eyes closed when they
when they opened the ark so he was
immune to the dark spirits that were
released from the ark
but bellock and his you know the the
his
his
cohorts were all taken out by their
carelessness their you know
their their lust for power
right of getting the ark i i feel i feel
that what a lot of people forget about
you know raiders of the lost ark is that
you know indiana jones doesn't win he
fails he fails in the end the villains
win
and then they become a victim of their
of you know
their own hubris they're you know
they're
taken out by
the the deceased spirits
it was never really explained